e
e e
like to uh open the February 14th
working session of the election law
subcommittee on voter registration and
impacts of nonresident voting
representative Newsome would you lead us
in the pledge please
Al to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liy and justice for
all all right I'd like to welcome
everyone uh the vast crowd here to uh
the election law subcommittee on voter
registration and impacts of non-resident
voting we also want to wish everyone a
warm and cordial Valentine
day
um uh I apologize for kind of a long
Soliloquy at first but um just a few uh
points of background that I'd like to
cover uh before we start to get into the
uh business at hand so we have a mission
statement that's been uh reviewed by the
minority head there and um and uh I'd
like to read that at the direction of
the chairman of the election law
committee this bipartisan subcommittee
is tasked with evaluating consolidating
and reconciling various 2025 house bills
concerning voter registration and the
impacts of non-resident voting
accordingly the subcommittee will review
the proposed legislation with attention
to
constitutionality any necessary
alignment with federal election law and
legal preceden the subcommittee will
consider historical context and
opportunities to clarify current
regulations the subcommittee will issue
a report to summarize its findings
conclusions and
recommendations so the subcommittee has
been currently tasked with the
evaluation of 10 house bills the
assigned house bills were listed in the
February 12th public notice for the
subcommittee work session for reference
these are in numerical order House Bill
323 365
472 618 684 and
686 all 10 of these bills have already
had a public hearing within the house
election law committee and additional
bills may be assigned to the
subcommittee once they have had a public
hearing by the election law
committee and if the subcommittee
determines that any of the bills under
our consideration can be returned
returned to the election law committee
we will promptly do
so with respect to the subcommittee
report mentioned in the mission
statement that will be due out of the
subcommittee on Friday March 14th and
that date will likely be the
subcommittee's final working
session for scheduling purposes I'd like
to ask each of the subcommittee members
to hold open your Fridays from 9:30 to
12:30 for regular working sessions the
subcommittee will not be meeting on
Friday February 28th uh which is a
school vacation week but the
subcommittee may have additional working
sessions in March so that the report can
be ready by its due
date um all subcommittee members
received two days ago a four-page
memorandum from uh Davis Allen our
committee researcher thank you very much
sir he's sitting in the back of the room
um on the definitions of domicile and
Resident relative to voting purposes so
we thank you for that memo appreciate
that good research um no doubt that will
come up in our discussions as we go
forward and we'll find a way to post
that for the public as well um if there
is any member of the public who wishes
to speak on this topic um the
subcommittee would welcome that
testimony I would note however that all
the sub subcommittee members have
attended the election law committee
public hearings on the 10 bills under
review and therefore the subcommittee
does not necessarily need to hear a
repeat of any public testimony for
specific bills unless there is a
specific question that the subcommittee
has about that bill or there's some new
insight that someone wishes to offer
relative to the subcommittee
focus so
we'll uh just please note that um we've
also invited various people to speak to
the subcommittee on the topic um the
Secretary of State's office uh has been
invited they will be speaking at various
times as well as the
ACLU um so we appreciate that um and as
I just a kind of final note um I'm an
engineer by degree and as I've been
thinking about these different bills and
considering them from kind of a process
engineering perspective um it seems to
me that there's a series of verification
events that occur in the voting process
for example let's consider the most
common voter the pre-registered voter
who goes to the polls on Election Day
that voter experiences a couple of
verification events in the process the
event or act of registration before the
election day addresses the question is
the voter
qualified the event or act of checkin on
the election day addresses a couple of
questions is the voter registered and if
so is the identity of the register voter
confirmed again I'm using this most
common voter example of a pre-register
voter who goes to the polls on election
days that represents a large major
majority of Voters in New Hampshire the
voter then receives a ballot in votes
and votes are counted in tabulate and uh
the review of the voter list by the
supervisors of the checklist addresses a
couple of the questions is the
registered voter still active and is the
registered voter still domiciled in this
town or city
Ward and those are important questions
to answer now those are only a couple of
illustrations for discussion purposes
but is sort of like these verific ation
events that are meant to ensure that New
Hampshire elections are safe and secure
and it's important to make sure certain
that uh voters go through appropriate
verification steps to ensure the
elections are safe and secure so that's
kind of the foundation that I'd sort of
like to lay for this
subcommittee
um we have a series of bills here and uh
again we'll um kind of muddle our way
through these but um there's um there's
a number of bills that are are from uh
similar sections or identical sections
so
um
the uh for for example um there
are four
bills from RSA
65913 they they are 323
um which is uh relative to requiring the
presentation of a government issued
photographic means of identification in
order to
vote and there
is as
well uh
472 requiring voters to prove
domicile which is rsa's
C and
then 618 and 6
684 are also from
65913 and
so
uh 618 is Rel enables election officials
to verify the single use of an out of
outof state driver's license presented
when a voter when a person votes by
using the centralized voting voter
registration database and then 684 is
preventing the use of student
identification cards as a means to
obtain a
ballot um and so I think
um for the purposes of this committee
I'd like to just uh start by looking at
those four bills they're relatively
short in
length
um
and um but they all pertain to
65913 yes sir if the if you would HB
also pertains to that as well as 317
which is not on the on the list
so uh thank you representative c
um if I
read the bill correctly there uh
385 so it's interesting they they attack
part of this is is our trying to
reconcile different parts of the um our
RSA and uh 385 that was the one you
mentioned right yeah that has I thought
I read it correctly maybe I did not um I
thought I I wrote down it pertains to
65412 but I may be
wrong no I think part two part two oh
maybe it's yes
oh I should turn this on oh okay so it
makes a cross reference
right so yeah so anything that
1569 last year affected this bill
basically is flipping it and putting it
back before 1569 so it affects a lot of
sections I can go through and since I
wrote it since you wrote it well OS
wrote it since OS wrote it okay um since
I can go through but it does it does
affect this one but it affects a lot of
others
too yes yes there are
um I was going to say so going because
that's one of the longer bills it's it's
19 Pages um I want to uh kind of review
that in
a uh perhaps future SE
if that's okay um just
because I I think that would give the
subcommittee a little bit more time to
prepare I know you're well prepared no
doubt as one of the authors um or
sponsors but um I think it would be
useful
to uh perhaps tackle that in a specific
subcommittee working session right so um
so before that I'll get a list of all
the sections yeah that that would be
awesome that uh thank you very
much um
so I would say
um if we go with uh 323
all right
so the that bill
as um
proposed
eliminates it doesn't eliminate but it
it rewards some portions of
that
um and
basically so it moves it it actually
technically moves the section that
discusses outof state driver's license
and non-d Driver identification
cards uh from that section and then kind
of summarizes it
in uh
Down Below in section 2A under one and
two so it basically says a driver's
license issued by the state of New
Hampshire or the federal
government the government issued ID and
then or an identification card provided
under the various rsas listed there to
six referencing
260 um also United States armed services
identification card
passports
um and it
eliminates other identification
cards that are not government
issued and it then it makes Provisions
for if the person has newly moved to the
state in a new section five
under 65913 Roman numeral
um and makes Provisions for
both uh out ofate driver's licenses and
nonidentification
cards or non driver identification card
sorry
um and then just reorders that so
basically it it requires a government
issued photograph means of
identification in order to
vote
um I
think that seems
to
address the Iden the verification of
identity adequately for check-in
purposes and things like that um
and it would address some of the
qualifications perhaps as well but
that's that's a
different
um section
that or
so if we're looking at that
from different perspectives of
equal vote you know treating you know
we're not creating a separate class of
citizens because we're requiring all or
two classes of Voters we're not
requiring
um we're not creating any subclass by
requiring all voters to
provide governmen issued IDs
we're it doesn't appear that we would be
because we're requiring it from all
voters we're making Provisions for those
who don't
have a driver's license or a non-driver
and you
know through the non-driver
identification cards
we're making um and then for those who
do have driver's licenses we're
addressing that
through
the aspects
of either a New Hampshire one or an
outof State one is also permitted under
certain
conditions so as we as we
look to this
particular one is there anything that
we um you know have have a con do we
feel that this would adversely impact
voter registration or that it would
somehow inhibit non-resident voting at
this
point um yes yes representative Lane
what what the simple answer is yes it
does impact it tremendously um and it's
clearly targeted I think at students and
um there's been there was no offer of
any proof of any fraud or anything by
any students in in when it was presented
and um
it it and I guess one of the questions I
had was my understanding at least from
some of the testimony was that the UNH
card May well be a governmen issued
ID and I guess that was one question I
had um because during the testim Tony I
think it got raised I can't remember who
raised it but it it may well be a
governmen issued ID because UNH is part
of the state government and I I thought
we should maybe clarify
that
okay uh I'd like to yes respond to that
I believe I believe um the question on
the um student ID was that they did not
have an address of their physical D of
their location where they live I think
it was just like a generic UNH
address I think that's what was brought
up so it's not really
telling on the ID as to their exact
living location so it it doesn't
identify the doile it has just like a
UNH and I think they may have even said
a possibly a PO box so I recall that I
think what they I'm sorry do we want to
just Converse or do you have to
recognize this I don't um why don't we
converse for the for the moment if if if
I am if I I do have a gavel here and I
will enforce it if if necessary I think
it it's good to have the discussion um
so let's let's um yeah just you know
that's what we did last year when we did
the campaign Finance one one and Jim was
I don't think Jim qua ever had to gabble
anybody so hopefully we'll um we'll find
out yes you're right on the PO Boxes but
my recollection was that that was for
the people who were living on campus and
that they came to a PO box if you lived
on campus they all got assigned a PO box
and that's so if you have a PO Box on it
you live on campus and if you don't then
it's not going to I don't think it has
an address but this is just for identity
purposes not for domicile purposes so as
long as has the picture and the name I
isn't this just for
identity so if a person
is is
pre-registered where the residency or
domicile has been already identified
that would be valid same day
registration I think that that creates
tremendous problems because you don't
really have
unless they're providing other evidence
of their doile address that's that can
be
substantiated um and I I do think the
the PO Box um as an address under any
circumstances has some
um
uh issues again just relating to how how
can you check and verify that that this
a legitimate residence or
domicile so
um so um the chair would like to
recognize one of our members and forgive
me I don't have your name memorized but
but please um please introduce yourself
and um thank you for uh coming up and
speaking yes thank you very much uh my
name is Michael O'Brien I um am a
lobbyist at pretty strategies and
represent America votes just wanted to
sort of echo representative l Point here
so IDs are used to prove identity so for
instance a passport which is a
government ID I could bring to the polls
to prove who I am but it will not have
my address on it right but that does not
stop me from producing a passport and
you saying y this is who he is it has
his picture it has his name it is an
official ID and therefore proves
identity I would then have to produce
something else beyond my passport so I
just want to make sure we're not sort of
convoluting uh the the purpose a New
Hampshire license could prove both right
it could prove both your identity and
your domicile if your address is correct
on your license uh we heard testimony
just this past week when you go to the
New Hampshire DMV and you go to update
your address what they say to you is you
can spend 50 bucks if you want right now
or you don't have to and you can just
keep your license as is and so lots of
folks have a license that is not with
their current address but they are up to
like they are completely within the law
they have done what they are supposed to
do and so when we're talking about ID I
just want to make sure that we're clear
that that is to prove identity it can be
used to prove domicile but it does not
have to be used to prove it um and in
many cases like I said with a passport
or something else it might not and
that's okay um I think as long as again
there is a secondary document that must
now be shown to prove it and I just want
to be clear about that for this
committee that we dealing with two very
separate things that these IDs
prove uh thank you very much Mr o'r are
you willing to take some questions sure
of course so so
um so to to your point though is
if there's a there's a registration
process during which different
qualifications must be addressed and
then there's the identity process for
checking in and receiving a ballot and
and and I agree that is that a governmen
issued ID that like a passport that does
uh verify
your uh identity would be suitable for a
pre-registered voter um and they
wouldn't and they would not have to in
that would you agree that in those
circumstances they would not have to
produce anything to prove their docility
unless they had changed recently so if
I'm a registered voter and I I show up
um to the polls to go vote and I'm I'm
already registered right so I show up I
you know what the law dictates right now
is that you prove identity they
certainly do read your address to you
right they we've all you go to the
checklist they say I say three Rockwood
terrorists I don't know if I should say
out loud but anyway uh and they uh and
they and then you know I get my ballot
but there is no as as discussed in the
previous bill right so you're there to
prove identity and so the ID works for
that purpose which is which is the
purpose of of what the law reflects
right
now and then uh for but for those people
who are registering same day voting sure
um they're going to at Le to
require um something to prove their
identity yep and then if they don't
have an address on that identification
they need something to prove their doile
Y and then if there are any other
qualifications pertaining to the right
to vote then sure yeah they would need
to prove citizenship they would Age um
you know all those things would would
have to be proved somehow um but again
an ID can prove multiple of those things
right as a New Hampshire license can
prove your age it can prove your uh doy
that can prove your identity it cannot
prove your citizenship as we've talked
about right and real IDs do not prove
citizenship um um but it could prove
three of the four and then you'd be you
have to produce the last document they
can but not always right and this goes
back to that it's not always going to do
that um so it is now accomp upon the
voter to make sure that they have all of
those documents um ready to produce for
the um for the supervisor checklist so
that they can be
registered um and that's again an ID a
college ID would prove one thing um and
we know that colleges work to you know
to help make sure students have all the
appropriate information but their ID
would just prove who they are and that's
that's the end of it and they have to
produce the rest of these in order to
qualify to vote okay thank you
yep does the subcommittee have any other
questions for Mr O'Brien at this
time maybe later yep sure yeah of course
and I know this might sound silly but
so when students provide their ID are
they showing a different uh another form
of their demile yeah I believe they have
to they would 100% uh un I believe has a
list of like where the kids live so that
they can cross check to make sure that
they're the right spot um oftentimes
they have a letter right with like this
is your dorm this is the address of your
dorm I believe they have to produce that
in order to prove that they live on
campus or as rep representative Lane
said if they live off campus right then
they would have to either either have a
license with that on it or produce a
lease or something to prove that they
are domiciled in New Hampshire they
cannot just produce their unid would not
be enough to
verify uh domicile for students and is
this the same for freshmen that are just
moving to New Hampshire and you know
within the couple months they can vote
based off of that information y so
they'd have to produce again their
student idea would prove who they are
and then they would need to produce
something that proves that they live um
you know in whatever dorm we live in or
again whatever apartment they're renting
whatever the case may be for that
particular student okay thank you and I
want to stress too it's not just
students that we're talking about here
right so you know let's say you work for
biee and you have a a badge and you know
maybe you forget your license at home
but you have your work badge because you
need to do you're going to work right
after right like we trust Bae I think as
a like a a pretty large employer in the
state to produce a badge that is and and
that's ultimately the way the law is
written right now under 1569 and
certainly the deputy secretary can
correct me if I'm wrong here but it's up
to the discretion of the moderator right
to say yes this is good enough or no
it's not good enough and we've sort of
said like we left it open a little bit
more under 1569 than we had under
previous uh legislation I believe
so and um when you're talking about the
proving residence domicile all that
stuff sure that occurs to check
qualification at registration correct as
opposed to under
65913 obtaining a ballot correct which
is what I thought we were talking about
with RSA
323 is at when going at the polls
to um get the ballot correct correct
correct so right so there's no uh
currently there's no reason to prove
domicile residency to obtain the ballot
correct correct that's exactly right um
and so this is right about during the
registration process is what we're
talking so all that stuff's already
happened when you registered correct and
even same day
registrants go to a different line
correct to to make sure all that flies
before getting the the the obtaining a
ballot is a separate time and what is
needs to be proven hopefully not too
much time but unfortunately this year we
did see some uh some pretty long lines
so um but yes
you do you you have to register first
and then obviously get your ballot uh
once the registration is
complete I would just I'm sorry no
go I just want to remind everybody that
we have a letter from both the clerk and
the moderator from Handover that's
really extensive that's that was
presented as testimony um that talks
about what they accept in Handover and
she mentioned several different like
really large employers that have um
different uh they take that ID and these
are for people just for the ID you know
to show that who they are and so um I
think I can't remember the names of the
companies but they're pretty big
employers and and I think they take like
Dartmouth hospital they take those as
IDs and huh hyperm yeah hyperm that was
one I couldn't remember and um so I just
want to remind everybody that that's in
there about what that moderator does and
uh and what that clerk does and what
they've worked out with the Dartmouth
students as well um and they do have
lists of who lives where on campus and
they provide that and the clerk I think
the clerk's office has that list when
when they're there so they are aware
from from a domicile standpoint if they
ever wanted to ask but um and they've
come up and I think the folks in Durham
do the same thing not so much maybe with
employers but I know for the students
they do because I used to have to
observe um over in durum and uh and
watched what they did so but
yeah subcommittee have any other
questions at this
point all right thank you Mr
all right so
um we've sort of looked at that
and uh We've looked at
323 um and I'd like to also look
at um one of the other bills that is
applicable to
65913 again recognizing that yes all of
these intersect at some point or another
but uh so the next one on my list is
um all right this is again another
uh short
bill
um it repeals 6591 131 Roman numeral 1
C and um provides that if the voter does
not have proof of res residency or
domicile um and then list you utility
bill lease deed similar documentation of
the voters dool address the ballot clerk
shall direct the voter to see the
supervisor of the
checklist and then they review the
voter's qualifications and determine if
the proof of residency or doile is valid
and if they are established the voter is
allowed to vote if the supervisor of the
checklist determines that they have not
been established they shall not be
allowed to vote um and it says a voter
not allowed to vote as a result the
determination of the supervisor of the
checklist may take an immediate appeal
to the Superior Court as provided in RSA
65412 Roman numeral
5 um all right so
again I believe just double check that I
believe this would
be we're checking
in but
probably have a circumstance
where one that's effective is not in the
purple book
right
uh that became effective on November
right so um
yes have to bear with me for a moment
while I look that up online I guess but
okay um
yeah so this is the hours of polling
section and then the
um and then the new
paragraph for C1 starts out just um for
so everyone knows if the voter does not
have a valid photo
identification uh clerk shall direct the
voter to see the supervisor of the
checklist see make sure I have the right
one
yep yeah so it seems that this bill is
trying to take uh remove what happens if
they don't have a valid photo ID and
insert if they don't have a valid
domicile
proof
which isn't required in any way shape or
form at this time at obtaining a b
which seems rather odd to me
right and just not a not a bill that's
sort of it's changing something that in
the wrong place if
anything to me I just don't understand
where they're coming from right and
unfortunately I think this was the one
the sponsor was not available to answer
any questions
on right I I think you're right I I
recall that thank you representative
Nome I do believe that is correct I
think that
is I think that is a problem this may be
one that that we end up returning to the
election law committee early
for
uh address
that well I think the word you're
looking for well I
yes I'm trying to give some difference
to the sponsors and and so on but
uh so
I think that this is the yeah my notes
my notes indicate that secretary seanin
said that there was no requirement to
show domicile when checking in and that
this was a conflation of two process
processes is that process processes
processes yeah uh and uh it it makes he
also suggested it would make check-in
chaotic and a disaster I think those
were his exact words right so I and and
I think um I think in agreement that you
know as as I think I said in my sort of
opening drawn out opening remarks that
um there is a registration process and a
check-in process and and if the two are
being conflated then um that is not
something we necessarily want to do it's
uh if I give the sponsor the benefit of
the doubt I'm assuming that perhaps this
was the thought process was the same day
registration and they were trying to
address that aspect but this is the
incorrect place to do that and I just
want to um I think my I was I may have
misspoken when I said the uh um sponsor
was not there I'm not 100% sure on that
I may have been looking at my notes on a
different bill so I don't want to I want
to remove my comment about that I'm not
sure no but she did she introduced the
bill very quickly and then left because
she had to be in another committee and
she did not take any questions so she
was here here briefly but then left I
just want I I was looking at my notes on
a different bill so thanks thanks for
clarifying that representative L I um I
look at this and I think it applies to
all the bills that we deal with is we
need to be very careful about
distinguishing registering to vote
versus voting and the registering to
vote um there's an inperson process
there's a by mail process and same day
process so same dat process is probably
very similar to the inperson
process and then the other is obtaining
a boat uh a ballot and voting which
would be in person and absentee so we
need
to keep the registering and and voting
separate yes and I uh thank you
representative C I think that's
absolutely right I think um we we want
to keep those two process
separate but we also want to make them a
Level Playing Field for all voters so
um but that Level Playing Field must
meet a minimum threshold of
um authenticity so that we can ensure
the public that our elections are safe
and secure so
um
at at this point I would
um I'm not sure if this if we can make
an official motion but I I think this
might be one that we could return to the
I'm not sure if this is an action that a
subcommittee could take but I think this
is one that we could possibly return to
the election law committee for further
action does um I would agree I just
don't know what the process I don't know
what the do we have to make a formal
Vote or do we just recommend it back go
ahead and recommend it back and I we
have some time to do it so we could we
could check in with we could do that and
then check in so we know the intent for
what we want to do with this particular
bill for that reason so I think let's
check in with
um uh the powers that
be do you do you happen to know Mr Allan
uh if a if the subcommittee is going to
refer a bill back to the main committee
is there a defined process for
that thank
you all right so we have I think we have
an action that we can take with this um
and
then um
you know I would I would note on just on
behalf of the uh Prime sponsor and the
other sponsors listed there that if
there are some good
elements um that belong in another
process we should consider those but
um um so before we dispose of this uh I
I encourage the subcommittee to review
this to see if there are pertinent
elements that we would want to uh use in
another bill perhaps uh for processing
purposes um in terms of you know if
proof of domicile is appropriate
under um registration and there's
elements here that are not already
addressed in the RSA then that might be
something worth considering it's it's a
homework assignment for myself to go
back and double check that to see if
there's any elements there that that
would be an improvement to the current
process uh currently defined process and
if there are then uh that would be also
one of our recommendations out of out of
at least the majority report uh and we
would um but we would still uh get this
bill back to election law so that we can
process these
um uh more effectively for the house
sessions as
well all right if I may yes
representative see this bill sort of
shows what happens when you conflate
different processes into this if this
Bill had had part one be uh dealing with
registration and part two dealing with
voting then we could have more easily
considered
it yes thank you represent C I think
that's that's important it it's
um as as the secretary State noted in
his testimony there was a conflation of
processes and I think that um we do see
that as as I'm sure many other
committees see that we we often see that
in election law where people are
conflating uh different
processes and um and
the so again just just like we need to
think about registration and then
checkin
to obtain the ballot and then we as rep
to C outlined we need to also think
about some subcategories that
occasionally
occur um during those processes so you
we have same day you know we have
pre-registered same day registered
absentee ballot aspects in in cases
where they may not have been a
pre-registered voter as
well so
um all
right so let us now move on to we've
addressed two of the bills under
65913 uh the next one
is
618 um representative C that is your
bill would you like to make um any
specific comments with respect to that
bill I'll give you the floor for the
moment to there's anything you wish to
say about that okay this one was um
dealing with
um using an out ofate um driver's
license or ID
for uh to go vote and the idea here was
that we're supposed to get if we move to
New Hampshire we should get uh within 60
days the uh a New Hampshire driver's
license and do any other things that uh
are incumbent upon someone changing
their
domicile and what this does is just
allow a one-time exception to use an out
of state driver relation assuming that
the person came just moved to the state
and had not yet had a chance to go to
the uh
DMV um so it
was basically to uh
um give people who just moved in the
state that
um opportunity to vote without being
harassed too much but the idea was that
the uh supervisor checklist and I
believe it was in there on
U
um yeah on page one line in
um 19 and 20 it says the ballot clerk
shall also advise the voter that this
out of state license or ID may not be
used for voting purposes
again
so if somebody is moving to New
Hampshire they need to do all those
steps that are incumbent upon changing
your
domicile right and this is thank you
representative C and just
um
and just for
context um I'll ref uh I'll refer people
to
um Mr Allen's memo that talks about um
let me see if I have that handy here but
um that talks specifically about
uh the definitions of dool and residence
and that um one aspect of this and I'm
just taking this from the statute rather
than um an inhabitants domicile for
voting purposes is one is that one place
where a person more than any other place
has established a physical presence and
manifests an intent to maintain a single
continuous presence for domestic civil
and civil purposes relevant to
participating in Democratic
self-government they have the right to
change
domicile but the uh but an intent to
change it in the future doesn't
necessarily uh apply in those uh
circumstances so the I think we we also
heard
testimony that once you vote you're
you're
now
um you know sort of making that
Declaration of an intent to establish
then the requirements
for uh Motor Vehicle Registration kick
in at that point or for uh LIC driver's
license excuse me so um that might be
something that the uh Secretary of
State's office could comment on if um
that's possible is with respect to a
driver's license whether whether uh when
a person votes for the first time using
an out of-state driver's license what
aspects kick in at that at that point
would you be able to uh accommodate us
here deputy secretary I welcome um
deputy secretary uh Hennessy to to the
subcommittee thank you for uh offering
testimony here today thank you sure
thank you for having me happy Friday
everyone uh Aaron Hennessy deputy
secretary of state I was just trying to
look up I know there is a well I'll go
through another bill that is in front of
a different committee um I believe you
may have just voted on it in the house
yesterday there is a bill that went
through house
transportation that requires the
Department of Motor Vehicles to use the
information that we collect in our
Statewide voter registration system that
identifies voters who have used an out
ofate out ofate driver's license um and
I I don't know the exact wording that
Transportation decided on but it would
require the DMV to then contact those
voters to say reminder this is state law
you've used this driver's license you
are required if you are driving here in
New Hampshire to get a a um a New
Hampshire driver's license but currently
what our office does there is
a um a different law and I apologize I
don't have it in front of me that
requires us to send um letters to people
who used an out ofate driver's license
to check in to inform them of the law
that they but there's no would say
there's no ramifications otherwise it's
just an in informing them that you
checked in with an out of state driver's
license but there's
no they don't need to follow up um to
get one um because of that
letter all uh thank you I think it was
House Bill 133 that from the
Transportation that um I if if memory
serves me correctly um um
so
uh
that um and so that would require the
DMV to I I believe contact these uh
persons who voted with an outof state
driver's license that now that through
the active voting they've declared their
intent to maintain that presence then
they have to comply with the
other uh legal requirements that New
Hampshire has established for those who
move to New
Hampshire yes I believe that's um I I
have not worded it as graciously no
doubt I have not worded it as graciously
as um the bill has but uh that's the
essence of yeah and and I would just say
that um the DMV I believe would not
contact somebody if when they were
provided the information from our
department um um that they their
database now shows that that person does
now have a driver's license so the two
database information would be bumped up
against each
other yes thank you as I uh just to
remind everyone the testimony during
that house bill 133 determined that
um I I think the year was 2016 and there
may be updated information but that the
compliance rate was something like uh um
less than 20% of those who actually
did uh transfer their their driver's
license over to New Hampshire it was I
believe 80 I think the actual number
that was used in testimony was 86%
failed to comply with the request and so
I think this is um certainly something
that we we want to make sure we address
because that level of compliance is
really unacceptable
um so hope hopefully House Bill 133 has
done that
um
and
um would I know this is kind of
preliminary question but would the
Secretary of State's office
anticipate
uh more coordination with the DMV for
the purposes of this or
or I mean you already you already sent
to them a list
right uh we we actually send we would be
sending the list to them now we already
have the information we already do some
letters um through our office um some of
the letters we won't need to do anymore
because they were affidavit related but
um this would require us we already do
have some shared information with that
department um because of Hava um Rel
Hava law requirements but this would be
and an easy database share uh
information share um if you can imagine
a report but um that's related to HB 133
right for this one the only the concern
that I have is that ballot clerks do not
under law have access to the Statewide
voter registration system so if somebody
did check in with an out ofate driver's
license or attempted to then they would
have
to we either need to change our
reporting on our checklist to identify
that that person had previously checked
in with an outstate driver's license um
which would be system changes and
possibly a longer checklist or we would
then have to send that person to the
supervisors of the checklist um so
similar to the bill that you were just
talking about um there would create
longer lines um and a little bit more
chaos at check-in because somebody has
to go to supervisors who who do have
access they would have to supervisors
would have to look up to see if they
used one previously in the in the state
svrs system however not every supervisor
has access on Election Day to the
registration system just because of
different constraints in our polling
locations including Wi-Fi and system
access
so it is there
So So currently
those
um that currently the Secretary of
State's office has that list of Voters
who voted using out of state licenses
that that's correct right yes so when on
on on Election Day if a voter checks in
using an outer state driver's license
they are the the ballot clerk either on
the paper checklist or um through the
pole pad checking process and then
ultimately through the p on the
papercheck list must put the two um
letter initials of the state that um
somebody checks in so if I am from just
moved here from Massachusetts I haven't
gotten my driver's New Hampshire
driver's license yet I use it to check
in to prove my identity and to receive
my ballot um they will put Ma on the
checklist and that would be then
uploaded into the Statewide voted
registration
system would the Statewide voter
registration system have the capability
to identify on a town or city Ward
level out of state voters who voted
there
previously so that thanks for the
question the that's what I would have to
say is that we would need to change the
report that we do for a checklist on
Election Day
um and then which would be a system
change with a cost related and then the
more information that we put on the
checklist the longer the checklist gets
so we were just looking at a bill that's
coming up this week that you're going to
hear that requires more information
right Al dealing in that same section on
the checklist um and our our take is
that um if we put more information right
in that spot we would have to add
another line for each voter which if you
have A500 page checklist now you have a
3,000 page check list so yes we can do
it it there's just some things to
consider if we were to do
that the
um
it do you do you know
would the Secretary of State's office be
able to supply this subcommittee some
metrics around this for example could
you tell
us the
the number of out of state voters at any
given Ward and you know what are the
top I'm I'm sorry the term out of state
voters there or out of sorry thank you
sorry sorry thank that I appreciate your
clarification there new some um uh
perhaps a Freudian slip I don't know um
is it is it possible to determine those
who have voted in New Hampshire using an
outof state driver's license and to tell
us uh some metrics to provide some
metrics around this you know did did I
I'll pick on Hudson did Hudson have 10
since I'm from Hudson did Hudson have
10 uh voters who are CLA doile and
Hudson who uh otherwise fulfilled all
the criteria but used a out
ofate driver's license for for that
purpose in the last election I believe
we would be able to give you that I'd
have to check um sometimes we're
constrained on what information we can
and cannot give and I don't know all the
details behind that but um I will get
back to on that and let you
know would you like a an email from me
as a formal request or sure I'll I'll
try and word it nicely so that um that
can be done all right great
um uh does the subcomittee I see um
would that information about outof state
driver's license usage be able to
Encompass the um exceptions to requiring
somebody to get a new driver's license
for example if you come to New Hampshire
and don't own a car I believe there's an
exception to having to get a new
driver's license would that information
Encompass that where somebody wouldn't
be
required to get a new ID that way so our
database does
not have um DMV information on that or
um car Registries um so no it will just
give you information about who used an
out of state out of state identification
to check in to obtain their
ballot thank you for taking my question
uh I was just wondering does the each
town clerk get a list of people who used
a u out
ofate driver's license or
ID uh you said it indicated the initials
for the state like ma or BT or something
like that um or the supervisor checklist
do they
get do they have that information for
each voter at the time of of the
election thank you for the question so
after an election the clerk will have
the paper checklist and it will be on
the paper checklist um so they do have
that information uh it's just not
summarized for
them so you would have to flip through
each of the pages to see um who voted
you who checked in to vote using an out
ofate ID okay uh as a followup um for
the next election will the supervisor
checklist know who used a announ state
ID for the last
election um there is no law requiring
the supervisor ERS to look to see how a
voter previously checked in to vote or
what there's no there's no look back
requirement like this this legislation
proposes so the the the supervisor
checklist do not have the information or
they're just not looking for
it I will say that they
um they are
not required ired to look for
it and if they were to look for it
there's nothing in law that allows them
to do anything with that information
does that make sense like they are
they're not on law
enforcement the only the DMV would be
the
only well I can't say I'm not a lawyer
and I'm not law so I can't say what the
DMV or the department of sa safety does
if somebody has an out ofate driver's
license beyond the I think it's 60 days
that they're allowed
to okay
uh for this particular bill then is
there no way that the uh that this could
be implemented based on what you have
now I will say that I think
um HB if it if HB 133 is the correct I
think that would be the better way to go
to Pro to require somebody to get a New
Hampshire driver's license um when they
meet the criteria of having to get a New
Hampshire driver's license when they
move to New Hampshire um only because
that would put in the department of
safety's um wheelhouse when the law
enforcement um side of New Hampshire
rather than in um an election officials
Arena where they are not a um somebody
who has the would say capacity on
Election Day but also
um under law is not required to enforce
a department of safety
law all right well then there's another
bill that uh just requires a total ban
on the use of an out ofate ID so that
would work to accomplish
this if that is your intent yes
okay hi thank you for taking my question
I so it does say that the um ballot
clerk needs to change um change the
address in red when they're checking in
with an out of state they're making a
notation that it's an out of state on
that
checklist so is it the supervisor of the
checklist responsibility
to have that on the next checklist is or
is this that doesn't go anywhere I I
guess I'm a little confused thank you
the checklist um for an election that's
printed out shows the the registered
voter's name and it shows their address
which they've proven to get on
to um the checklist under current law it
would be a physical piece of paper or a
New Hampshire drivers license um under
previous law they could have used an
affidavit to attest to that domicile so
it'll show the domicile of where they
live but it will not show how many times
they used an out ofate driver's license
to prove Identity or which state they
used it shows their voter
qualifications uh thank you uh if I may
ask another further question
is um is it
possible or or do you would you foresee
any problems if the Secretary of State's
office provided to the supervisors of
the checklist kind of a separate form
that would be able to capture outof
state driver's licenses for
easier
um check-in process during the
registration on voter day and then uh
per the proposed Bill a look back
process as
well thank you for the question I think
adding another piece of paper or another
separate checklist that maybe have to be
used in the same day would be more
complicated so if you're going to
require um additional information on the
checklist I would just say keep it to
one checklist keep it to one one
database that's printed out or one poll
pack had checkin because if there's
multiple things that somebody has to
look at or fill out at the same time um
humans are involved and you may have
errors in making sure that they agree
with each
other if I may just maybe I didn't
understand your question no no no I I
think it's good I think your answer was
fine I I
um it is a it is a busy time during a
election day and to when you are doing
same day registration and you have
multiple pieces of paper with which uh
you must
process a a large number of Voters you
certainly want to minimize the
challenges and difficulties that
supervisor the checklist or moderators
or other election officials have to deal
with without a
doubt
um it
it's it would seem to me that if if a
person
is
presented if if an election official is
presented with a list
of out of uh of Voters who used an out I
want to say this correctly um voters who
used an outof state driver's license in
a previous
election a and that was limited to
that
particular town or city Ward or town
Ward or what have you
and there was some basic information
about which state it came from and the
the identification of the person and and
those
aspects
um
then it that shouldn't be too onerous a
task again I'm assuming that there's not
large number of these type of people but
again if we need the metrics on
that so my my question was I don't I
don't think it sounds like it's too
honorous a
process well I guess I would I would
just have to ask the supervisors are not
the ones that check people in to vote so
they would if we gave them a list that's
the ballot clerks are the ones that
check people in to vote and they look
for
identity um the concern I have about
excluding out ofate driver's
license from checking in again um if
somebody um if somebody's not required
to get one for example if my father
who's over 65 years old lives in
Florida comes to live with me
permanently please don't if you're
listening um if he comes to live with me
permanently he's not required requ ired
to get a New Hampshire driver's license
um he can if he's not driving he can use
his expired Florida State driver's
license um to prove his identity to go
get a ballot as long as he's met his
other qualifications to prove domicile
his age and his
citizenship so we
could definitely add an extra space on
the checklist the checklist may get a
little longer notifying a ballot Clerk
that they've previously used an out
ofate driver's license to check
in if that's what you're looking
for so I could see in those
circumstances so in thank thank you for
that response uh that that is a
important aspect that we need to make
sure we address in this process um
would uh a person meeting the criteria
that you described
um maybe not directly related to you be
able uh for your sake uh be able to uh
obtain a non-driver identification from
New
Hampshire yes is that
process extraordinarily difficult or I I
don't believe it's difficult I think
it's it's going to the DMV to get that
ID but it is a process yep
representative
bernham thank you um do we know how many
um out of state licenses are used each
election do we have an idea I I think
that's the report that um the chairman
wanted me to get and I I will see if I
can get that I don't think there's
restrictions around that type of
reporting since it's public checklist
information so but I will see if I can
get that for you
thank you okay and and then just another
one question here so depending on the
frequency of how many outof state
licenses are used for
identification do you think it would
really double the checklist or maybe
just a page or
so I would I would have to wait to give
you that information and also figure out
what the programming is because if if
it's a if it's a line if it's a field
where it's either filled or not fill for
every
voter then it would be a field for every
voter which would add space to the
checklist but again I can't tell you
that for sure unless we've programmed it
to figure out exactly what you're
looking for and how much space that
would take
up thank you
uh yeah I I I'm I'm trying to think
having done some programming myself um
being an engineer uh I under understand
that if those were not in the initial
requirements um you know a new space is
sometimes uh interesting challenge for
databases and things like that
so if um so we when you're registering
in state when you're registering voters
who already have a New
Hampshire I identification a driver's
license
um when they C they're they're capturing
the state at that point or do they is
that is it just assumed to be New
Hampshire so I think we're conflating
two different things registration and
voter checkin and this
bill is obtaining a ballot so that's
voter checkin versus
registration yeah
okay thank you
yeah and there and the questions just
keep on coming so uh representative Nome
thank you
um is it fair to summarize this as
saying that this bill would
create a for a violation of DMV regs the
penalty for that would be a loss of
constitutional right to vote
I don't think I can answer that question
because I'm not a lawyer okay yeah
sorry um I just I wanted to go back to
your comment oh I'm okay I want I wanted
to go back to your comment about um the
out of state driver's license for those
who
don't um who don't drive here and um I
think we heard testimony um I think it
was from uh uh Olivia zinc from open
democracy on a personal level about
taking somebody um who was 92 years old
uh lived you know in a wheelchair lived
in a um if I'm not mistaken some kind of
um uh nursing home or a care facility
and so she would not be able to use her
that driver's she's from Maine she had a
main expired main she would not be able
to use that more than once even though I
mean and and maybe not for us going to
DMV is hard but there's a lot of people
going to DMV is hard um if you don't
have a
car you're not driving so you don't have
a car to get there and and then you're
and the other thing is it's not just
there's a large population that going
through and getting there and having
maybe have to take a day off from work
to do it it just doesn't seem right
right and I guess it's not I guess my
question you is and what other what
other give me a
minute we also heard about yukaba voter
not yukaba but military family military
don't need to have an instate license
how do you handle
that um with your reports if there're a
if they're a military person and they
come in with do they get marked down as
using an outof state license
that's a good question I don't know what
they would present as for identity they
may be presenting a military ID and
again this is not this is not ID to show
domicile it's ID to show identity so
they could be showing a government
issued military ID with their picture on
it
um hypotheticals I'm not very good with
because I come with up with lots of
different options for you it yeah no I I
get it now I just I was wandering under
this bill and that's not really for you
to answer but that it's a good point it
is just for ID so
thanks representative C uh yes um just
to uh follow up on all
this if somebody vote uh register same
day voting they are then still
registered for the next
elections yes okay so if this bill were
changed
to limit the U out ofate driver's
license to same day
registration and that the normal
registration in in advance of an
election would require an
instate driver's license except for
seniors would that
work I would say again you have to look
at DMV law which I'm not a lawyer nor do
I work for Department of Safety
but if I had just moved to New Hampshire
and established my domicile a week
before the election and did not get to
the DMV yet to get a New Hampshire ID it
is difficult sometimes to get a DMV
appointment within a week
I think you'd
be not allowing somebody to vote be even
though they would be
qualified well as as I was trying to
present it maybe I didn't word it very
well um allowing same day registrant to
use an outof state license okay or an
instate if they have already taken care
of it but for the normal registration
period before the
election the they would need to have the
proper
instate ID except for
seniors I have to take this one back to
my team on that
um would that not be creating two
different classes between seniors and
non- seniors with what would be
acceptable we always have at least two
classes of Voters we got absentee voters
and inperson voters we've got old voters
we've got young voters
um any any two combinations of words you
can come up with a
list I think if we can borrow from the
American Disabilities Act we're we're
trying to do reasonable accommodations
for different
scenarios um and so
uh for those who are no longer driving
certainly if if a if someone was still
driving they would be required
to get a new license wouldn't they with
some exceptions out there for example if
they don't have a car in the state they
don't need to get
one so if there are a student coming in
from somewhere else and they don't have
a car in this they don't bring a car
with them which I'd be willing to bet
most certainly freshmen especially
um will not have cars if not most
students generally or the Stu the car
may they have may still be registered to
their parents they would not be
required to get a new driver's license
here is my
understanding we will probably have to
uh take that up with with someone on the
legal side because if
they've as we've
heard if they voted they've now declared
their
intent to be in New
Hampshire and therefore they have to
comply with the other applicable
laws
but which as they're currently written
very well may not require that
license so the solution may be over on
the other side rather than
here but I but I agree that I think
delving deeper into that aspect may be
required and and I also think that if
the ultimate goal is to deny them the
ability to vote that's a severe penalty
for just not
getting a driver's
license and I'm not sure it's
proportionate to the
crime all right well there's obviously a
few things to consider here um for this
particular
bill um
and we need to make certain
that uh the appropriate exceptions are
accounted
for and you're right there maybe some
other solutions that reside more in the
DMV side of things than such as HB 133
uh tried to
address
um are there any uh fur further
questions
for at on this particular
Bill we let's give you a little break
here perhap uh are there any other
questions um at this
point uh on uh 618 for deputy secretary
Hennessy no I don't have a question for
her right now but I have something I
that's just come to mind okay
so I have a mother who's recently had to
move in with me that I have to care for
and she requires care when I'm not home
either which is challenging so uh and
she's a voter her her mind is all there
but her body is failing in movement so
it was very challenging to um get her to
her uh City Hall to get an absentee
ballot physically for me it's a lot of
work so looking forward I'm I'm and now
that she's uh possibly going to be
living with me permanently I think about
how is she going to vote because I she
wants to vote uh she'll be moving into
my uh town so that that we' have to
she'd have to
change part of me wonders is there's
something we can do with and and this is
just a thought but it can we do
something that is
um she probably won't be able to
physically go to vote um any longer so
she'll probably do an absentee ballot
but for those people who do want to go
and have the proper assistance to do
that is there can we have some kind of
identification like at the town and City
level where they can retrieve that to
make that process just a thought I'm
throwing out there versus DMV versus
showing that they're living in a
particular place with a or it say a
college or School level as
well that it's all the same yeah I mean
it's I don't it's uh but it would be
through the town or city that they
reside in not through a school but
through the town and city where they're
voting
in is that I'm just throwing a thought
I'm just trying to see where this
information could be
captured and
processed without going through DMV in
licensing the driver's license it's
obviously like my mother is in driving
and her license will expire and I'm not
going to probably take her to DMB
because it does take almost a month to
even get an appointment so just kind of
throwing that out there something to
think about but anyway thank you
something like a voter ID
card I've seen that in other States I
don't know that I've seen it in New
Hampshire could certainly be used for
voter but it's also just an ID in
general like this is VI the town that we
reside in and here's my photo with that
all that information captured in one and
that could be definitely used for
voter from that because you're voting in
your town and City so why not have that
common thread of identification
Mr O'Brien we welcome you again to uh
the subcommittee for Testimony sorry
thank you uh Mr chair again my name is
Michael O'Brien with pry strategies on
behalf of my client America votes um and
just for you all I I know I'm around
here a bit but um this is my 12th year
sitting around the election law
committee um in various hats and so been
immersed in this for a long time um just
quick on the 60-day uh piece the first
time I interacted with this uh was when
I had moved I lived in New Hampshire in
an apartment we just bought our house um
my wife was uh the theater director at
um Wescom high school and I was driving
home on a snowy night and thought that
the breakdown Lane was a right-and lane
and so took a right in the breakdown
Lane and some lights flashed behind me
uh and the police officer pull over and
said do do know and I said oh I'm really
sorry I mean I thought I legitimately
thought it was a right-and lane that's
what it was there for and he took he
said you were from around here and I
said no I I live I already give my
address so what whatever uh I live in
Auburn he said oh your license is
Manchester and I said yes I haven't
updated it yet and he said you know you
have 60 days to do that so first I just
want to be clear that it's not just out
of state right if you move within State
you have 60 days the penalty for that
for me though he was nice to me and did
and took Mercy would have been a ticket
right I would have gotten a fine from
the state for not following up with
motor vehicle law um to emphasize the
point going from a fine to not being
able to vote is a is a pretty big jump
the second thing I want to just
reemphasize from my what I said earlier
if I show up with an out of state
license because I just moved to New
Hampshire it does not prove I live here
right I need something else so I think
we're once again conflating two things
here that are very different one is
proving who I am right if I had I'm from
Rhode Island originally um I try to hide
the accent as best I can every once in a
while it slips out if I show up with a
Rhode Island license it still proves Who
I Am the end of the day it proves who I
am I need something else if I have that
R Island license to prove where I live
and that it is in the state of New
Hampshire and so I just don't want us to
it feels like we're crossing this line
again where we're saying we need to do
an instate license because it's going to
prove where I live except again I I will
have to prove something else while I
register um in order to do that so um
and the last thing I just want to in
addition to some of the things we've
talked about um before we had to start
scheduling our presidential primary
earlier and earlier and earlier
sometimes the presidential primary Falls
within 60 days of the next election
which will be for most residents of New
Hampshire the March town meeting and so
it is possible that I could vote in two
elections in this state well within the
60 days uh and not have yet violated
motor vehicle law at all um and so when
we put this sort of one election
restriction you could also be there
could be someone who was well within
their rights to not have changed their
ID yet um but is now hung up in this
restriction so I just want to be clear
about all those things and especially
again identity is proved by license it
can prove domicile but it does not have
to and if it does not you must produce
something else and so that's that's
really all I
have right so again um I think the less
for today is you know there is
registration and there is checkin and um
at
least the requirements to demonstrate
either do not NE should not be
conflated um it they are sometimes
jumbled up for same day registration and
other aspects like that but but we need
to as a subcommittee make sure that we
continue to keep them separate and
um I think a Statewide
um we need make sure that that that we
account for
these election circum I'm not sure I've
I've remember hearing that in during the
public testimony perhaps it was but
the we need to make sure that if there's
a local election and then a primary
sometime in the you know within that
period that people are still uh unable
to vote I know you
know so uh you you had further comment
please I was just going to say in
goodness knows we have enough special
elections in the state that often times
they could fall within each two so there
were
just lots of ways of which this could
run a file without someone running a
file the 60 day uh notification of the
DMP all right thank you uh do any
uh Mr uh representative c i just um
wanted to point out that and it was
pointed out in testimony on one of the
bills we heard I think last week uh or
this week
that if you move within New Hampshire
and notify the DMV you do not get a new
replacement card so it has your old
address on it
uh until it's time to renew your
license if the state
police radio in the to DMV and they can
find out your current address and know
that it's been updated but other than
that it's not on the
card yeah that's correct he asked me and
I answered honestly which was I guess my
uh my mistake but again luckily he let
me uh he let me uplook so I appreciated
that I I I remember doing that and they
the back then this was a while ago um
the DMV just gave me a
sticky uh thing with my new address to
put on the back and that was supposed to
last for a couple years
um fortunately I didn't get pulled over
um I didn't even get the sticky they
just told me to use a Sharpie on the
back yeah obviously a a prudent cost
savings measure by New Hampshire so we
we commend the department of motor
vehicles for being prudent with the
taxpayers dollars and uh doing that and
saving the cost of stickies on the
backup driver's license so
um any other questions for Mr O'Brien
thank you so much appreciate
that all
right so I think we've
um we've looked and examined through
618 fairly thoroughly here this morning
I think so uh uh rep the spon the prime
sponsor acknowledges that so um if I
could I'd like to move to then the next
one that we have uh which I think is
unfortunately
oh yes Mr Allen
yes uh would you uh would you yeah would
you mind just coming up to the
microphone and and uh responding to that
so um and do introduce yourself in your
position and uh if you can restate the
question that I asked thank you Mr chair
uh for uh the record I am Davis Allen I
am the committee researcher for both the
election law committee and for this
subcommittee of election law um so the
question you and the subcommittee had
asked earlier was the procedural
questions regarding how to report back
to the main committee um on your
decisions determinations on the bills
that have been referred to the
subcommittee um my colleagues have
provided uh answers that um we would be
having a subcommittee vote um relative
to any recommendations that would come
out of the subcommittee uh it does not
have to be a roll call it is up to uh
the subcommittee to determine how they
will go about it uh examples came from
subcommittees for uh Commerce in which
they just do uh raising their hands to
get the count um there should be a work
session uh sheet uh or work form um that
the subcommittee would have uh and that
would be utilized for that uh and then
the subcommittee chair will usually be
the one to communicate the
subcommittee's recommendation to the
full committee either during a full
committee work session or the relevant
executive
session thank you Mr Allen and uh we
would also um make the standard motions
as it were for each bill is that correct
I I I do have work session forms in
front of me
and it appears that
they uh have the the normal motions
ought to pass ought to pass amended itl
retained it so on
um so those would be
um those are the Motions that the
subcommittee would make on a given bill
is that the implication there that is my
understanding it was not explicitly
stated but I would gather from the
information provided that is
correct just as a followup um could you
could you ask um if there are any other
options that we have I think we you know
for this particular bill I think we know
what we probably want to do but if
there's any other options that are
available to the subcommittee I'd be
curious to know what they would be so if
if you could look into that that would
be much appreciated yes sir all right
thank you so much
all right so
um so the last one so 684 is the other
Bild that I wanted to look at at least
um for right
now um
this is another bill that is
specifically addressing the
subsection and so I
wanted again my my uh kind of goal here
for at least the first part of this
meeting or second part after the
Soliloquy was to to try to address some
of these bills short bills that have um
a common RSA section in them so that we
could you know we're sort of looking at
the same subject at the same
time um
so
uh so again let me just uh briefly
briefly review this uh House Bill
684 um it's an act
that
um as written by OSS States uh
preventing the use of student
identification cards as a means to
obtain a
ballot
um it does not
um oddly enough the bill itself does not
prohibit the use of student ID cards but
instead requires driver's license issued
by state or federal
government uh identification
cards uh under
26021 and various subsections there or a
non-driver's identification card issued
by the motor vehicle
division uh Department agency or other
office of any other
state um and then more uh armed services
identification cards or United States
passport or passcard so those are the
types of identification that would be
taken and um just the the main body of
the bill I kind of uh laid down the
examples first here but the main body of
the bill says a valid photo
identification shall show the name of
the individual to whom the
identification was issued the name shall
substantially conform to the name on the
individual's voter registration record
show a photograph of the individual to
whom the identification was issued so um
so far so good
um and
then so name photograph for
identification
purposes expiration date that has not
been exceeded by a period of more than
60 days here it carefully notes that
except that a voter 75 years of age or
older may
use uh an otherwise qualified form of
identification that has an expiration
date that has not been exceeded by a
period of more than one year so
again the desire to keep a relatively
current identification
means
um uh photographic means um I believe
and then uh and then the rest States the
following forms of identification
bearing a photograph of the voter she'll
satisfy the identification requirements
and it it's that list I read earlier
driver's license identification card arm
Services identification card or a
passport or
passcard from the
US so
um again except for the poorly worded
title I don't think it it
uh it just makes a require requirement
rather than a Prohibition so I'm not
sure why that particular title was
uh used but
um I think perhaps it went to the intent
of the bill because all the student ID
things in the existing law are not there
so I agree with you I don't think it's
the best way but I think that's what
they did when they wrote it is they
rewrote it to it exclude all the student
ID I want to uh check and see
if if that
is
6593 to a
it does
remove some subsections of this of
student identification cards which are
not
um ostensibly well uh remains to be seen
perhaps but are not
us issued by
a federal or state
government responsible
for those sorts of specific
identifications although the section
above the 2A section above the numerated
list doesn't say government issued does
it or am I just missing
that no those are C captured in the
first four right those are examples of
all examples of government issued but
and those shall be accepted but as you
said that it's not an
elimination of other items that the
paragraph above says the the
requirements are it shows the name that
matches the registration and it has a
photograph and it's basically not
expired that those are the require the
three requirements of a valid ID to
obtain the
ballot and that the the numerated list
of four just gives examples of things
that hit those
three
requirements right um
itn't so it doesn't yeah but we saw that
uh the other day with a different Bill
where the analysis statement was exactly
the opposite of what it was trying to do
so right and we yes and and we
recognized that the OS had an extremely
large number bills to process during
that time and so that we will extend
Grace to both sponsors co-sponsors and
the OSS exactly for potential
inconsistencies
um so to me if you're
eliminating uh five I believe was the
one in current law is being
eliminated that you might as well
eliminate one through four
because those are clearly going to hit
name photo not expired if that's the
goal of the legislation
here uh representative Nome can you
comment on the not what do you mean not
ex when you said not expired well that's
one of the requirements in the in that
paragraph 2A is that the ID is not or
essentially not expired I think there is
a grace period um more than 60 days yeah
yeah except for voter with an exception
I note that they that the sponsor did
raise the um uh exception for the voters
uh 65 years of age or older up to 75 I
on behalf of those who are in that
decade between 65 and 75 I uh thank the
sponsor for that sort of courtesy as
recognizing the youthfulness of people
between those uh parameters so I I do
appreciate that
um so I
think
um there are uh I believe when this came
up or maybe this was on another bill um
that talked about government issued IDs
I do believe that that kind of language
is used elsewhere in the rsas I I know I
have seen that specifically so I need to
uh do some research on that I think
that's that's kind of really the L
hint I'm mixing up my words it's the
Lynch pin um or hinge point
and I was comingling those uh terms um
that is is important
um uh deputy secretary
Hennessy would would you be kind enough
to entertain a few more questions with
regard
to um identifications if you know in as
much
as you can I I apologize
I thank you sure I will try yeah I we
and the subcommittee greatly appreciates
it um so just a a a
question
generally
um on government issued IDs for you know
New Hampshire state or other Federal
issued IDs is there a capability for the
Secretary of State's office to
easily um verify the validity of those
type of government issued
IDs is that easily doable or I'm sort of
in in circumstances where the
secretaries of State's office might be
required to
verify identity based on government
issued IDs is it is it easy enough for
the Secretary of State's office to do so
thank you for the question I will say um
we are not required to validate an ID
the IDS are all shown locally to local
election officials um either to a clerk
who intakes a voter registration and ver
looks at the
identification um a supervisor of
checklist who does um voter
registrations either at a meeting or
same day registration or a ballot clerk
that would look at the identification
but there is we do not have a
um any means to make sure they're
not fraudulent in any way I guess is
that what your question
is maybe um so uh we well certainly we
want to prevent fraud so um so the
ability to check that
it you know in certain circumstances
certainly would be beneficial but but
perhaps that's not the
uh the most relevant Point let me uh let
me try another let me see if I can ask a
better question for you in your election
manual
procedure um you identify
different um I forms of identification
that would be accepted and currently you
just basically follow the statute is
that correct yeah we follow this we do
follow the statute um and the statute
yay we we don't get to make stuff up
which is great um uh yes we follow the
statute yes all right uh thank you
I if so if an election let me ask
another question if an election official
were to have a question about a
particular form of
identification would they would they be
calling your office to adjudicate
that great question um I have received a
question one time about a tribal ID and
my response was yes those are valid
ideas that you can accept as um proof of
identification so we do get questions on
is this form of ID okay um and we will
go to the election procedure manual are
the law and um we basically recite back
the law to people who have questions um
and I believe probably the AG's office
may get additional
questions
um and then other election officials may
bounce questions off other election
officials but we were not the sole
source of um question answer
answering if I may just a quick followup
to that
um is there a
uh po following elections is there any
sort of a debrief between you and the
AG's office about these sorts of
questions with regard to you hey did you
get any identification questions and you
know are there opportunities to clarify
things in the procedure manual or the
like yeah good question our office is in
I'm not going to say constant
communication but very frequent
communication with the AG's office um
especially around um Law changes and any
um any information that we distribute to
the public um for example today we
issued a press release around HB 1569
reminding voters if you haven't
registered this is what you need to
bring to register to vote um and after
specifically after elections our office
goes um discusses with the AG's office
what some of their representatives may
have found at polling locations when
they do the AG's checklist which is a
checklist of all the requirements that
each polling location is supposed to
have
um if there are frequent questions that
come up um our our offices will discuss
them together but I can't say that what
type of ID is a frequent question that
we
get okay thank you very much that that
was very helpful
um all right
any any any other
questions oh representative Lane you and
thanks for being here it's very helpful
um
how many instances of ID fraud are I
mean are you aware of say in the past 10
years that would be a question for the
AG's office okay yep is anybody
coming from the AG's office not today we
can certainly no no I mean later we can
invite them yes yeah and yeah I because
I'm just I just want to make sure we're
solving a problem that's really out
there um so I that was my question for
both when I was fumbling before for on
uh the other bill that that was the same
question so I'll I'll ask AG so thank
you any F not seeing any further
questions um I want to thank you again
for providing that testimony I would
suggest um if we could take maybe a
quick 15minute break and and
um that would allow representative Lane
and I to have a brief discussion and
then maybe a separate caucus or and then
reconvene at in approximately 15 minutes
would that be
okay all right so we will uh recess or
break for 15 minutes and resume at
approximately 20 of
12 Mr determined before we do that did
um uh Mr Allen I think had a looked like
he was approaching the mic I don't know
if he had an answer for us oh yes did
did you have a further answer for us
thank you uh please yeah then uh for uh
we will uh postpone the uh break for for
the this important update of information
from Mr Allen thank you Mr Allen for
again uh providing answers to our
subcommittee thank you Mr chair happy to
be here happy to support the sub
committee and the greater committee um
so relative to the question of what
motions and options are available to the
subcommittee uh it is only the standard
motions that are allowed to be made um
uh if the subcommittee cannot reach a
majority uh
recommendation um that is also
acceptable and the subcommittee chair
would then report um you know the
differing opinions of the subcommittee
um and um outside of making any motions
uh the subcommittee chair can also in
those executive sessions or work
sessions of the greater committee can
relay any information that is pertinent
to the recommendations and decisions
made by the
subcommittee thank you Mr Allen that was
very helpful again welcome appreciate it
all right we will now break and we will
uh still reconvene at approximately 20
of
uh see you
then
e
e e
all right so we'll uh reconvene the
subcommittee work session here
um
and let's see at this point we're going
to take a look at taking action on one
bill representative Lane do you have a
motion you would like to make sure I
would like to move that we recommend or
that we uh itl uh
hp472 Representative blae makes a motion
that we itl HB 472 requiring voters to
prove domicile is there a second I'll
make a second thank you thank
you representative C makes a second
here so just one moment while I capture
this I'm My Own clerk here
um
February okay um so uh all right so the
motion is itl it's been moved and
seconded uh let's have discuss
discussion on this is there any
discussion representative Lane um sure
I'll just speak to the motion I uh
during testimony we heard that this bill
uh conflated uh dool and um and uh
identification and that uh we re really
felt that given that we needed to
distinguish it between registration and
voting and um for that reason we felt
the bill as written didn't was confusing
and we would just prefer to itl it and
we'll move on to some of the other bills
that we have before us I don't know if
that's enough
but any further comments from the
subcommittee sure thank you uh yeah I
agree I just uh want I believe that the
although it's a it's a good bill I it's
just in the wrong location pertaining to
the RSA that's addressed in the bill so
for that reason
it it it does have a
conflict thank you all right thank you
representative bernham uh again I I
would also Echo what has already been
said by both Representatives Lan and
Burnham is that it really is a
conflation of these two uh processes the
registration versus check-in and
um while you do have to provide proof of
domicile when registering you do you
should not have to prove that at checkin
and so we need to make sure that we keep
the swim Lanes clear and that um those
two processes are not conflated in any
way and for that reason that seems to be
um
a
uh an appropriate uh analysis of the
situation so at this point um we're
allowed I believe as Mr Allen explained
we are allowed to take simply a um a
vote uh simple vote we don't have to do
a roll call
um and so we'll just take uh all those
in favor of moving House Bill 472 as itl
to send back to the election law
committee for further processing um
raise your
hands all right five to zero so um
okay so at this point um the
committee has
uh I'm not sure of the exact right
wording but we'll say has moved this
bill back to the election law committee
on um the basics that while it has
merits it does conflate the registration
and check-in process and then therefore
is in appropriate is inappropriate at
this time for further
consideration all right so thank you for
uh that um we've uh congratulations
subcommittee we've accomplished at least
one one thing today um yeah we made our
load lighter and that's that's always a
good thing so um let me just look at we
we have approximately another 45 minutes
and I'm wondering if we can tackle
a few others
um were there other categories like what
you did here that refer to one or yeah
I'm thinking that it might be possible
[Music]
to
um ah no I I misread it
[Music]
ah no
I
don't so at at this at this point so my
dilemma is that um we start to get into
the longer bills if we try to
combine um those that uh intersect
similar rsas and again I'm going to
reserve um 385 since that is 19 Pages
I'll reserve a full session for that
that um at some other
time
um 365 is
that that's the one about proving
citizenship
yes 385 is is is the n 19 pager I'm not
I'm not going to do that today
um I
think let's ju just bear with me for
just a second here
um we could
do
um let just see if there's any
other why don't we we look at at least
discuss
for
um House Bill 686 it's it is three
pages it's requiring a voter to provide
identification when requesting an
absentee ballot um why don't we take
that as
our um next task for today we will will
basically try to discuss
this
and um see see what sort of um
information we can do on this so let me
just kind of review this very quickly
the
analysis um States it requires anyone
who requests an absentee ballot to
provide a copy of a government issued
photo identification along with their
absentee ballot application it requires
that the application be notorized and it
requires a person to cure any errors in
the application in person and to prove
their domicile to a city or town clerk
and
then
um just
summarizing uh section one has is a long
form uh encompassing
approximately two pages
where it goes through a list of
different
qualifications that would make the
person eligible for an absentee ballot
it
includes uh absence due to Residence
outside the United States religious
observance and
disability
um
and so I I'll just um there's there's
quite a list here so just for the
purposes of the public being aware of
this they can look it up online
themselves but um just to remind us as a
subcommittee it's a someone who is duly
qualified they're absent and will be
absent until after the next
election um or they're unable to
register in person due to a disability
so they're requesting the appropriate
forms they'll be absent on the day of
election they're confined to a penal
institution um for misdemeanor or a
waiting trial they're requesting a
ballot um for a primary
election
uh they cannot appear in public on
Election Day because of a religious
commitment observance they're unable to
vote in person due to a
disability they cannot appear at any
time during polling hours because of an
employment
obligation and that and for the purposes
of this application this takes care of
the care of includes the care of
children and infirm adults with or
without
compensation um and then it also has a
winter storm warning
Proviso where um on the Monday prior to
an
election they can use this if a
storm warning blizzard warning or ice
storm is predicted for the next
day then on the on the next page it um
it's if you're elderly or infirm or have
a physical
disability
um or if you anticipate school or child
care or adult care will be cancelled and
you then need to care
for um children or infirm adults
who uh could not be taken care of by
these Services during that
day uh due to the closure of those
Services
um and then it says anyone
who it gives a warning that anyone who
is using the absentee ballot for
inappropriate purposes uh are subject to
uh being guilty of a misdemeanor
and then it asks for specific uh things
uh presidential primary State primary
general election uh declaring party for
primary election purposes and then uh
takes down the information from the
applicant so the name the voting doile
or home address um and then identifies a
different address if other than the home
address address if if you're away for
that extended period uh phone number
email address signature and so forth and
so on and then um and then uh someone
who's assisting someone who has a
disability who cannot sign directly
allows uh that person to
sign uh as completing that form on
behalf of that person who has the
disability and then uh page three then
gets into
um really the the notary aspects of this
uh process so and this is um and this is
the
additional aspects that are that are
being provided here that most of what I
read before is not new it is current um
but what is new is the applicant must
sign and notorized this form to receive
a absentee
ballot
um and the person who witnesses and
signs assists a voter with the
disability executing the form shall sign
and notorized
um the moderator will
compare the voter's signature
application with the notorized signature
on the notorized statement and if the
applicant does not have the form uh
notorized um the bill proposes that the
applicant's ballot application will be
rejected um subject to curing the
defective application under
6576 colon 6
um
and there's also a uh requirement to
provide a color copy of a valid
government issued photo identification
to receive an absentee ballot I believe
that the sponsor explained that um this
is less easy
to
um
Forge and
if and states that if if a color copy of
the photo identification is not
provided
um then it will be rejected other than
the ability to to cure the defective
application under
6576 um and then fin finally um it goes
on under
6576 and adds a new
section um any applicant whose
application form does not comport with
the requirements above under
6574 um may appear before the city or
town clerk subject to their ability to
verify their domicile with the clerk and
amend their application form to cure any
and all defects so again just require
iring that if they're going to cure it
they do so with the clerk uh city or
town clerk so that it
is um really seen by someone who serves
as an election official and it's it's
being uh
appropriately uh remedied under those
circumstances
so um that is the bill before us
and really the I think the
key perhaps the key part is the
notorized
up
um all right having kind of covered that
bill are there any comments from the
subcommittee representative
C uh yes
this um ends up being a situation
where uh if other legislation passes
they could be required to get two
notaries one on the application and one
for the absentee
ballot uh the uh form on the outer or
the inner envelope
and just under that I'm I would think
that
uh on this I would be more interested in
having the notarization on
the
um inner envelope of the ballot
itself as being the person who filled
out the ballot rather than the
application but I don't think it needs
the notary needs to be done
twice um and also I just noted on page
three line five where it says applicant
must sign and notorized I think that
would probably properly be uh need to
say and have notorized
because presumably the applicant is not
a
notary and I I would also guess that a
notary would not be able to notorized
their own
documents could you point that out where
that is again
uh page three line
five and it just says the applicant must
sign and notorized but the applicant
doesn't notorized it the he has it
notorized
by somebody
else and
also if
the
applicant um goes into the town
clerk the town clerk clerk should be
able to issue that and we had a bill
that would
allow the uh Town Clerk and Deputy clerk
to be able
to
um essentially notorized the document
even if they are not an actual notary
public so my concern is that this is
asking
[Music]
for uh we would end up we could end up
asking for an absentee voter to have to
pay for two
notaries and I think that's a little
excessive all right thank
you representative
Lane I I would a agree well I I think
asking the notary on on either place is
in inappropriate and I guess not
inappropriate but
unnecessary um but focusing on this bill
um not everybody has I mean I don't have
a color copier I I just don't understand
why it needs to be a color copy and I
don't understand um why it needs to be a
copy um I mean we've wor we've lived
without it all this time and uh even and
the clerk's Association was against this
too so I guess I'm I'm just not quite
sure about you know one a color copier
but you're also going to be requiring
people people who want to vote Fon T to
either have a copier or get to a place
with a copier and particularly if
they're infirm or you know not able to
get out of the house they're not going
to be able to get to a copier I I just
don't understand the requirement I think
it it disenfranchises a lot of folks
I
um your your point is noted I think
again I we we want to have everyone at
an on an equal playing field and I
don't I don't know that we want to
have
um for for absentee
ballots the
Act
of registration and check in the the two
processes that we've T been talking
about are
distinct and and should should
be distinct and different um but not not
so so different as but not
I'm sorry I'm want to make sure I say
these words correctly is there should
also be for absentee
ballots um a registration and a check-in
process it by Nature has to be different
because of the nature of absente ballots
but um the same questions that are
answered for the pre-registered election
day voter that I discussed earlier still
need to be answered for those applying
for an absentee
ballot and so I think I think we should
look at this and
determine um you know is it answering
those fundamental
questions uh again in order to ensure
the safety and security of our
elections but um also
to make accommodations for the person
requesting the absentee ballot but also
still have Level Playing Field for all
voters having to go through the same
sort of verification steps in the voting
process so
um it
it
uh it does seem as if this
notorized and so it has some uh issues
with
it in lie of
I I I
guess you know my initial thoughts are
if some election official or or town or
city Ward official is not able to
complete those
processes then a a not a
notorized an acceptable
alternative they're not a election
official but they have the they have
sufficient qualifications to
authenticate the identity of the
voter and and some of these other
qualification aspects that we might need
u in that sort of circumstance I I need
to think through this a little bit more
but I think I just want to give the
subcommittee an idea of where I'm
thinking about this or I'm thinking
about this I want to make sure we we
answer the same questions for all voters
in terms of
verification but I also want to make
sure um and and I want to make sure that
if you know the normal processes if
these can be done by election officials
then they we shouldn't need an uh a
notary um but in the absence of election
officials or approach appropriate local
government official officials or
Secretary of State office officials um
asking those same sorts of verification
questions then um it it might be good to
have the notary as an
alternative
to these other things if the other
things cannot be obtained in those
processes if that made any sense uh I
see you you look
me quizzically yeah no no it made sense
I guess part of the problem of getting
the C you know color copy or you know
going out to get um a copy at Staples or
wherever you might go to get one um is
still you're still going to have to go
out find a notary you're going to have
to find somebody to come to your house
you're going to have to be able to
afford to pay them um and it just and I
think somebody mentioned that might be a
pole tax but I I don't know I'm not
saying that but it just it it just seems
like there are barriers being placed
that we don't have now excuse me that we
don't have now but yet no one has given
us any evidence that this is really a
problem so again I come back to are we
really solving a problem here or are we
just
theorizing uh thank you representative
Lane I I think my
my response to that is I I I think we're
trying to
achieve a level of consistency of
verification and
we're again if if the the earlier
remedies of town
officials you know local government or
state government Secretary of State's
office for
example cannot answer those verification
questions who is going to do
that perhaps and I'm I'm not saying that
this is the solution but perhaps a
notary public who can attest to the
validity of the documents presented to
that notary republic without color
copies or what have you but they can
attest to the authenticity of those
documents and uh confirm that you know
these things have been appropriately
presented and then authenticate that
through a notary I've only had a
something notorized
very infrequently so I'm going by memory
which is over 10 years old at this point
um and so you know in that case it might
be it is something worth considering it
that that could be an option
um the the only other option would be
you know we would we would have to
you know we would have to look at you
know how can we then confirm
these you know qualifications if they're
if they're registering or identity if
they're
voting um or you know checking in a
sensibly to obtain the ballot if they've
already
pre-registered how can we confirm those
in in a manner
uh that Prov provides the same level of
verification that you know the
pre-registered election day voter goes
through so I think again that that is
just sort of my uh forgive me simplistic
way of looking at this but I think if we
can uh Endeavor to kind of make sure we
have that Level Playing Field and then
for those who have unusual
circumstances um if accommodations need
to be made make accommodations but then
also make sure that those accommod
ations
are uh sufficient to fulfill the
verification requirements so I I'm still
processing this need to think about this
but I think I think that's
um I'm not I'm not saying
that uh I I don't believe that
notorized for every absentee B so I
think that's very clear but I think it
could be an option again when these
other verification components are not
being uh fulfilled through election
officials or state officials how how can
we how
can how do I know that
my my vote is not disenfranchised by an
absentee ballot that hasn't been
properly verified or you know identified
and so it's it's the risk is you know do
do I know whether or not
it's authentic and and um so um those
are my my thoughts on the matter uh I I
see my colleagues to the right who I've
I I have not in I've been speaking to
the left side of the room here I or my
left side of I you asked the question so
I apologize but uh um he was first he
was first all right so representative C
what wisdom can you impart to this
subcommittee okay you touched on part of
this was uh uh
on the color copies and stuff like that
if you're having somebody notorized it
if they can see your driver's license or
whatever ID you're using it doesn't have
to have a copy
um the concern I have
is
um this application I believe is for
somebody who has already registered to
vote so at that point we're only trying
to identify that it's the correct person
who's requesting the absentee ballot and
not part of this but when they send the
ballot back we need to make sure that
the ballot came from that same
person uh
so uh the other part was the distinction
of if they apply in person at Town
Hall they uh the town clerk should be
able to take care of all that and it
should not necessarily be notorized um
it's only if they're mailing in the
application from wherever they might be
to get a ballot sent to them that the
question comes up of the identity of the
person mailing it in but I think the
biggest
concern for absentee voting is making
sure that the ballot
itself is from the correct person I'm
not as worried about uh who's applying
for
it all right thank you representative C
appreciate those comments um
representative brunham thank you
um and I might be opening a can of worms
here
but today we have technology we have
phone devices where we could take a
picture of a person we could take a
picture of an ID it's colorful it's
beautiful how is it possible that it
could be submitted and is that
legal that is a that is a good question
we should um certainly um the banking
industry and the uh Finance Industries
have uh extensive means of identity
verification that are in use
today um and provide
uh ostensibly very
secure confirmation and verification
authentication of identities so
um you know Perhaps Perhaps that is
something
for
[Music]
um perhaps that is something for future
consideration
um and
I I'm I'm guessing that that would
probably have to be done at the state
level and so um yeah so yeah she's
so so uh so um uh so uh deputy secretary
Hennessy um I not I'm not sure we we um
need you to answer any questions but
we're um in our discussion if I may
summarize for you um we were
discussing the fact that the banking
industry the finance Industries have a
lot of remote identity identity
authentication technology in use today
um you know every people can do remote
Banking and people can
do uh remote other things with financial
people
um um and
therefore that that
is uh you know certainly a technology
option that we could consider I it is
not something that I would ever want to
consider at a local level because
of uh the cost and mandating it to the
local towns and City Wards um and
also um they certainly don't have the if
you will the cyber
security uh vigilance NE they don't
necessarily I don't want to um uh diss
any of our local it folks but they don't
necessarily have the full cyber security
uh capabilities that say the state of
New Hampshire might have and so it would
seem that um one possible alternative to
this
identification um for the purposes of
submit sub mitting an absentee ballot
could be um technology that would come
through the Secretary of State's office
of course this would require of Finance
uh commitment and other Provisions no
doubt we would have to think more
thoroughly about what that would entail
I'm not sure it's um something that we
could do in this term because of the
finance bills having to be in already um
but that's something for future
consideration and I I think that's
that's um good but we're we're sort of
checking down our list of
Alternatives you know directly with the
local state or directly with the local
Town officials or election officials uh
perhaps with the Secretary of State's
office um maybe in absence of those two
things and a
notorized C's point if if we're asking
um really for an identification
associated with the ballot at this point
um is that the right mechanism and then
and then we got into the discussion
about uh Banking and finance technology
that could authenticate identities as
well so there's a lot of different
points discussed I don't think we'll
come to any conclusions but we will come
to the end of the meeting shortly so um
so um I'm not sure we're going to
resolve anything here I think um the
points of about um the wording for
notorized is uh
inappropriate it would have to be have
notorized um and that sort of thing and
um so I think we'll need to go back and
and look at this a little further and
see
um what can best be done with this
particular bill but but I think this was
a good discussion a lot of different
points were
raised um um representative we yes I
just want to follow up on representative
Burnham's suggestion because
um you could take a picture and then
send it you know send it via email as
part to the clerk so I mean again that
would require a computer and some some
technological expertise which not
everybody has but you know um but I
think from a if you're thinking about
alternatives
um Dan Healey who's was speaking for the
clerk's Association he says most of his
requests come in via
email rather than letter so if you're
emailing the request you could perhaps
attach you know but um it's an image
really it's not technically a copy I
guess but um but maybe we have to look
at that I'm I'm I'm still not sold on
that we need to do this but um um but if
we're going to do it that's another way
to offer another alternative um and I I
guess I will just stop
there well I guess I I won't stop there
um I would say that it it's a I think
the goal is to have basically how to
obtain an absentee ballot match how to
obtain a ballot in person is the goal
here and I would say that since we have
no evidence of fraud happening at the
absentee ballot level without IDs to
then instead of strengthening that or
making it harder or however to Define
that is to then make the in-person match
what we currently have which is an
affidavit which is what we had several
years ago and that way if you don't have
that ID in person you're back to the
affidavit and the two different uh
methods of voting uh and getting that b
not voting of obtaining the ballot
whether it's in person or absentee those
two methods would match up at that point
which would easily and
cheapest um solve this that
issue I I thank you representative
Newsome I think that that's an
interesting point I think um if if we
were still
doing um the traditional legal
definitions of affidavit I I would
certainly agree that that would be
good as we heard from uh I think uh Mr
Richard in in the election law committee
testimonies uh a couple of sessions ago
um he he pointed out that currently what
we're calling an affid is more of a
self-verification and so I think
um I I want to avoid
um
uh turning the check-in process into a a
cold porter musical anything goes so
um I think we have to be a little
careful uh of sliding backwards on on
the uh in-person check-in versus
tightening up the absentee balance of
course this
is uh the direct Direction I I sort of
lean toward and you're certainly right
to uh want to lean in other directions
from me
so um all
right any uh are there any further
comments from the subcommittee at this
point in that case uh would I hear a
motion to adjourn for the day and we
will res resume uh next week so moved
second second all right um all in
favor all right so um thank you all um
for a productive uh first work session
here of the sub committee on voter
registration and impacts of non-resident
voting um we there will be a public
announcement for the next um series or
next session coming out next week and um
it will have one less bill on it uh or
at least well maybe one more yeah maybe
one more you never know so uh stay tuned
and uh again I want to thank the uh
subcommittee members and uh dep
secretary Hennessy for coming today I
know everyone is very busy and this uh
for some of us has been our third day up
here so for all of us it's been our
third day up here so um and some of us
more than that so appreciate your uh uh
diligence and your efforts to uh help
improve election law so uh everyone have
a wonderful happy and lovely Valentine's
Day e